gentleman the president needs men of  action your new mission is to make sure  he wins this election  what are we  talking about here sabotage Espionage  infiltration bare knuckle tactics same  [ __ ] they do to us every election we  have recruited covert operatives to  plant surveillance inside the Watergate  to our White House employees on the  payroll for God's sake don't get caught  [Music]  third grade burglars forever  people need to understand why we did  what we did sometimes I find it  confusing  and we did it  [Music]  why is the FBI here Howard we are  willing truly  they should fear me I know things that  could tear this country apart  who  really killed JFK  oh Christ